>> Dana: ALREADY, MARK
MEREDITH REPORTING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
MARK, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, NIH DIRECTOR
DR. FRANCIS COLLINS.
DR. COLLINS, WELCOME BACK TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY," IT’S SO GOOD
TO HAVE YOU HERE.
>> Dr. Collins: GREAT TO BE
WITH YOU, DANA, GOOD CHANCE TO
TALK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE WITH
COVID.
>> Dana: WELL, LET’S START
WITH THAT.
IT’S BEEN A PRETTY CONFUSING
WEEK FOR AMERICANS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND JUST WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH COVID AT THIS
STAGE OF THE PANDEMIC.
WE HAVE THE DELTA VARIANT, IT’S
SPREADING ACROSS AMERICA.
COULD YOU GIVE OUR VIEWERS IS
CLEAR AND EXPERT NATION AS
POSSIBLE ON WHAT WE SHOULD KNOW
AND WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
RIGHT NOW?
>> Dr. Collins: I WILL VERY
MUCH LIKE TO DO THAT, LET ME TRY
TO STRIP AWAY ALL OF THE
CONFUSING INFORMATION AND TRY TO
HIT THE HIGH POINTS.
THAT KIND OF COME INTO
CATEGORIES.
THE BAD NEWS AND THE GOOD NEWS.
SO LET MR. WITH THE BAD NEWS.
DELTA IS SPREADING.
WE KNOW IT’S EXTREMELY
CONTAGIOUS AND CERTAINLY IN SOME
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY LIKE
MISSOURI, ARKANSAS, LOUISIANA,
IT IS REACHING VERY HIGH LEVELS
AND WE ARE NOW ONCE AGAIN SEEN
CASE LEVELS PER DAY CLOSING IN
ON 100,000, WHICH WE HAVEN’T
SEEN SINCE FEBRUARY.
SO THIS IS REALLY A DIFFERENT
VIRUS THAN LAST YEAR AND
EVERYTHING WE LEARNED ABOUT
COVID A YEAR AGO, YOU’VE GOT TO
SORT OF HIT THE RESET BUTTON ON
NOW HOW WE NEED TO REACT TO IT.
IF WE ALSO ARE LEARNING -- AND
THIS IS NOT PARTICULARLY GOOD
NEWS -- THAT VACCINATED PEOPLE,
IF THEY GET INFECTED, WHICH IS
WHERE, BUT IT DOES HAPPEN, IF
THEY PRETTY HIGH VIRAL LOAD’S,
WHICH MEANS THEY COULD ALSO BE
PASSING IT ON TO OTHER PEOPLE,
EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE A VERY LOW
RISK OF GETTING SERIOUSLY ILL
THEMSELVES.
THEY CAN BE A VECTOR.
THAT WAS THE REASON FOR CDC
SAYING IT’S TIME IN THOSE PLACES
WHERE THE VIRUS IS SPREADING,
WHICH IS ABOUT 75% OF OUR
COUNTIES, TO PUT THE MASKS BACK
ON WHEN YOU’RE IN INDOOR SPACE,
WHETHER YOU ARE VACCINATED OR
NOT.
THIS IS THE BEST WAY TO STOP THE
TRANSMISSION OF THIS VERY
CONTAGIOUS VIRUS.
SO THOSE OF THE BAD THINGS.
THE GOOD THINGS --
>> Dana: GO AHEAD.
>> Dr. Collins: THE GOOD
THINGS.
THE VACCINES WORK EXTREMELY
WELL, INCLUDING AGAINST DELTA.
IF YOUR VACCINATED RIGHT NOW,
YOUR CHANCE OF GETTING INFECTED
BY THIS GOES DOWN BY AT LEAST
THREE AND A HALF OLD, YOUR BIKE
WITH IT OF HAVING SYMPTOMS GOES
DOWN BY EIGHTFOLD AND YOUR
LIKELIHOOD OF GETTING REALLY
SIGNIFICANTLY ILL IN THE
HOSPITAL GOES DOWN BY 25 FOLD.
THAT’S AN EXTREMELY ENCOURAGING
NEW SET OF DATA FROM THE REAL
WORLD WHERE WE ARE TRACKING
THIS, SO VACCINATIONS ARE STILL
OUR BEST HOPE AND THEY ARE
WORKING BEAUTIFULLY, BUT, OF
COURSE, WE NEED TO BE SURE MORE
PEOPLE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
SO THE OTHER PART OF THE GOOD
NEWS THAT I’M HAPPY TO SEE IS I
THINK WE MAY, DANA, HAVE SEEN A
TIPPING POINT NOW WHERE
VACCINATIONS ARE GOING UP EVERY
WEEK.
56% INCREASE IN VACCINATIONS IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS,
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE AREAS
HARDEST HIT.
GOODNESS, LOUISIANA HAS TRIPLED
THEIR RATE OF VACCINATIONS IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS.
THAT MEANS PEOPLE ARE FINALLY
SORT OF SAYING OKAY, I’VE WAITED
LONG ENOUGH, LET’S DO THIS, AND
I WOULD LIKE EVERYBODY LISTENING
TO THIS THIS MORNING TO THINK
ABOUT THAT.
DON’T YOU WANT TO BE PART OF
THAT TIPPING POINT?
AND IF YOU HAVEN’T YET GOTTEN
VACCINATED, THE EVIDENCE IS NOW
OVERWHELMING.
IF THERE ARE MANY THINGS THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO BE EASY FOR YOU
TO DO IF YOU’RE NOT VACCINATED.
COMPANIES ARE STARTING TO
REQUIRE THIS.
JUST LET’S GET OFF THE FENCE,
MOVE FORWARD AND BE PART OF THE
WINNING TEAM THAT GETS THIS
DELTA OUT OF HERE.
>> Dana: VACCINATED PEOPLE ARE
SOMEWHAT FRUSTRATED.
THEY WANT TO GET BACK AND GO
ABOUT THEIR LIVES WITHOUT MASKS
AND IT’S FRUSTRATING TO THEM
WHEN THEY FEEL LIKE, YOU KNOW,
HERE WE ARE, I’VE DONE THE RIGHT
THING, BUT NOW WE’RE GOING TO BE
POSSIBLY HAVING TO GO BACK TO
THIS, INCLUDING IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND MASKS AREN’T A MAGIC BULLET.
THE VACCINES AREN’T A MAGIC
BULLET BUT THE VACCINES ARE
WORKING VERY WELL AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE HAS BEEN
THAT UPTICK.
DO YOU THINK IT’S NECESSARY FOR
CHILDREN TO HAVE TO BE MASKED IN
SCHOOLS AS THEY START IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS?
>> Dr. Collins: WELL, IF THE
GOAL HERE IS TO REDUCE
TRANSMISSION OF THIS VIRUS
AMONGST CHILDREN WHO ARE NOT
COMPLETELY IMMUNE FROM GETTING
SERIOUSLY ILL, OR HAVING THEM
PASS IT ON TO OTHERS IN THEIR
HOUSEHOLDS, THE MASKS ARE THE
BEST THINGS WE GOT RIGHT NOW TO
REDUCE THAT.
I KNOW PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED AND
IT’S GOTTEN VERY POLITICAL AND
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
TO BLAME.
JUST PUT ALL THAT ASIDE AND LOOK
AT THE FACTS.
IF DELTA IS AS CONTAGIOUS AS WE
NOW KNOW IT IS AND WE WANT TO
TRY TO PUT AN END TO WHAT IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT UPTICK RIGHT
NOW, WEARING MASKS, IF YOU ARE
UNDER 12 AND CAN BE VACCINATED
WHEN YOU’RE IN SCHOOL, IS A
REALLY SMART THING TO DO AND I
KNOW IT’S TIRESOME AND KIDS AND
THEIR PARENTS ARE SICK OF IT,
BUT LET’S THINK ABOUT WHERE
TALKING ABOUT LIFE AND DEATH
HERE, WE’VE LOST 620,000
AMERICANS ALREADY.
IF WE CAN SAVE EVEN A FEW OF
THOSE BY PUTTING MASKS ON
OURSELVES AND OUR KIDS, WELL, IT
SEEMS LIKE THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
>> Dana: BUT AT SOME POINT,
DON’T WE HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT
THERE WILL BE SOME RISK?
>> Dr. Collins: THERE IS RISK
IN BEING ALIVE RIGHT NOW, FOR
SURE, AND RISK IN GOING AROUND
YOUR BUSINESS, WHICH I THINK WE
ARE ALL DETERMINED TO TRY TO DO
AND AVOID LOCKDOWNS, WHICH IS
SOMETHING WE DON’T WANT TO HAVE
TO GO BACK TO, BUT IF WE ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE,
WHETHER IN BUSINESS OR IN
SCHOOL, TO DO THINGS THAT WE ALL
REALLY VALUE, PUTTING THE MASK
ON IS THE BEST WAY TO ENSURE
THAT THINGS DON’T GET WORSE, SO
IT SEEMS LIKE A SACRIFICE WORTH
MAKING.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT.
I ALSO WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS.
THIS IS ABOUT MY MOM BUT I DO
THINK THIS IS REPRESENTATIVE OF
A LOT OF PEOPLE ACROSS AMERICA.
SHE IS 74 YEARS OLD.
FOR THE LAST 18 MONTHS SHE’S
DONE ALL THE RIGHT THINGS,
THEY’VE STAYED HOME, SHE HAS ON
HER BUCKET LIST A ROAD TRIP TO
NEW ENGLAND.
SHE LIVES IN DENVER.
SHE’D LOVE TO SEE THE COLORS
THIS FALL, BUT SHE’S CONCERNED.
I THINK THAT AS SHE IS FULLY
VACCINATED, THIS IS A TRIP SHE
SHOULD TAKE AND TAKE THE
REPERCUSSIONS IF SHE NEEDS TO IN
A CROWDED AREA, BUT WHAT SAY YOU
ABOUT PEOPLE GETTING BACK TO
LIVING OUR LIVES AND LEARNING TO
LIVE WITH THE VIRUS?
>> Dr. Collins: I THINK SHE
SHOULD DEFINITELY GO.
I THINK SHE SHOULD DO ALL THE
CAREFUL THINGS, OBVIOUSLY WHERE
IN MASK DURING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION, BECAUSE THAT’S
STILL A REALLY SMART THING, AND
REQUIRED IN MOST PLACES, AND AS
YOU SAY, WEAR A MASK INDOORS IN
CROWDED PLACES, BUT ACTUALLY
NEW ENGLAND IS DOING A LOT
BETTER THAN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY, SO SHE’S GOING TO A
PLACE WHERE THE INFECTION RATES
ARE QUITE A BIT LOWER.
I WOULD STILL URGE HER TO DO ALL
THOSE CAUTIOUS THINGS, BUT YEAH,
GO AND ENJOY THE COLORS.
THIS IS NOT A REASON TO STAY
HOME AT THIS POINT.
WE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS HERE
COMPARED TO WHERE WE WERE A YEAR
AGO.
WE JUST WANT TO DO SILLY THINGS
TO CAUSE THE DELTA VIRUS TO COME
BACK EVEN STRONGER.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT,
DR. FRANCIS COLLINS, A PLEASURE
TO HAVE YOU THIS MORNING,